partout dans le pays les affiches
électorales et portraits géants des
candidats tapissent le paysage et les
façades des immeubles
les visages sont pour la plupart connus
des libanais qui n'ont pas été appelés
aux urnes depuis plus de neuf ans le
hezbollah peut prétendre à une majorité
au parlement pour la première fois
depuis 2005 selon les derniers sondages
[Musique]
hassan nasrallah le dirigeant du parti
de dieu a fait campagne sur ce qu'ils
considèrent comme une victoire de ces
miliciens en syrie qui a nécessité de
défendre l'identité chiite de son
château fort dans la békaa la résistance
et ses armes ont besoin d'une protection
politique at il dit à cette foule de
partisans rassemblés dans l'espoir de
voir l'homme en chair et en os cette
protection viendra de vos votes at il
déclaré mais parvient vidéo
la liste du courant du futur le parti du
premier ministre sortant saad hariri
pourrait faire élire moins de candidats
qu'en 2009
mais l'homme lui est plus populaire que
jamais si l'on en croit les sondages et
les analystes politiques
il se verra de nouveau confier la tâche
de former le nouvel exécutif par le
président michel aoun mais une nouvelle
loi électorale qui introduit pour la
première fois le système de la
proportionnelle suscite l'espoir de la
société civile
c'est le cas de la coalition coup la
nawa thani tous du peuple qui appelle
les électeurs à se mobiliser contre les
ténors de la politique traditionnelle
mon doigt
joumana haddad journaliste écrivain et
activiste est l'une des candidates
vedette de ce regroupement
maintenant c'est le moment de nous
révolter de dire non à la corruption
n'ont offert que le vicieux dans lequel
nous nous débattons depuis depuis au
moins 30 ans non aux intérêts personnels
au défense de l'intérêt du pays
nos divisions confessionnelles
oui autour d un discours qui plaît aux
jeunes mais qui passent difficilement
auprès d'une large part de la population
qui a bien peu d'illusions veut pouvoir
changer les choses
les gens ont été déçus
souvent pour ne pas dire tout le temps
au liban donc je comprends mieux j'ai
complètement la conviction que nous
allons les surprendre il faut juste nous
donner la possibilité de le faire s'ils
ne votent pas pour nous
ils auront choisi la défaite on a besoin
de gens comme ça parce que les députés
traditionnelle et tout bon c'est un peu
la mafia là ils sont entre eux qui me
passait je te passe à suivant doit être
fait pas d'eux
le 183e pays dans la corruption
c'est catastrophique lycées qu'ils
représentent une minorité qu'au fond
bien peu de choses ont changé au
lendemain des élections
mais le style précis le décider pour moi
je les lui laisser le penser pour moi
ironise les soeurs kesrouani dans cette
vidéo qui est devenue virale à la veille
des élections
elles se moquent de leurs concitoyens
elle reproche aux libanais de se
plaindre d'être dirigé par les mêmes
personnes depuis 30 ans en oubliant un
détail important
ils ont élu ces mêmes personnes pendant
30 ans ici marie-eve bédard radio canada
noda lundi matin